how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I have something very interesting and
very exciting that I want to talk about
today so earlier this month this image
popped up online and I didn't really
think anything of it at first I just
thought it was advertising for Avengers
in game in Japan which it is but a few
days ago I was with a buddy of mine who
was born and raised in Japan and is now
living in the US and I remembered the
photo and I brought it up and asked him
what it said and as it turns out it says
a lot and it could potentially say a lot
about some huge plot points and Avengers
endgame so my friend translated this for
me and I'm going to go over what it says
in this video quick reminder my new
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway still
continues if you would like to enter for
your chance to win a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero a winner will be
chosen at the end of this month ok so I
show my friend this photo who is from
Japan and speaks Japanese and I asked
him what it is and he says well it's
about the New Avengers in-game film that
comes out in April and about how the
Avengers will end so I'm like whoa wait
a minute what do you mean the Avengers
will end and he says it literally says
Avengers will end so what this is is a
promotional piece for Avengers in game
in Japan with reviews on it from people
who have already seen the movie all of
these texts on this photo are quotes
from people stating why you should see
the movie so this is a promotional piece
for Avengers in game in Japan trying to
get people to go see the movie when it
comes out and right at the top it says
Avengers will end I'll talk about the
quotes in just a minute but let's talk
about that line Avengers will end this
obviously is not the end of the Avengers
they're not going to stop making
Avengers movies in fact phase 4 is going
to kick off right after Avengers in game
with spider-man far from home so it's
not the end of the Avengers but it could
possibly be the end for some Avengers
there has been so much talk about Tony
Stark and or Steve Rogers dying in
Avengers end game and it has been stated
that there will be permanent deaths in
Avengers end game and now we have a
promotional piece from Marvel about
Avengers in game that says
vengers will end on it so this is even
more evidence pointing to the fact that
some Avengers will die if not one of
them will die in Avengers endgame and
listen to some of these quotes that are
listed on this promotional piece Marvel
portrays the extremes of human struggles
slash inner turmoils what do dreams
justice hopes and strengths mean a never
ending story
excited to see the heroism and hope in
the times of devastation and of course
the Avengers are coming to a close
they're all pretty dramatic talking
about the extremes of human struggles
and inner turmoil and times of
devastation so as expected it sure does
seem like Avengers endgame is going to
be pretty heavy and dramatic but also
keep in mind that the Avengers ending
doesn't necessarily mean that some
Avengers are going to die they could
very well go on to defeat Thanos and
some of the Avengers such as Iron Man
and Captain America could retire and
pass their Mantle's down to other people
and some New Avengers could come in and
of course when you have a movie that
involves time travel and/or alternate
dimensions there's always the
possibility that somebody could die but
be brought back at the end but the Russo
brothers have stated that there will be
extremely high stakes and consequences
in Avengers endgame so you just never
know but let me know what you think
about this promotional piece in Japan
let me know what you think about
Avengers will end do you think that some
of the Avengers will meet their end with
retirement or with death let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you